a diver in Hawaii was treated to a
mesmerizing sight when he spotted an
octopus changing color spotted at Ava
pinnacles Oahu Hawaii
the octopus almost appears to light up
with color in case you didn't know
an octopus uses camouflage as its first
line of defense against predators the
invertebrate uses a network of pigment
cells and muscles to change color and it
makes it so it instantly blends in with
its surroundings this defensive tactic
enables the octopus to evade predators
such as sharks and dolphins octopuses
are often found in warm tropical and
also temperate waters around the world
[Music]
while most octopus species are smaller
some can grow to more than a hundred
pounds that is enormous
[Music]
in addition to camouflage an octopus
also use this ink as a defensive and
offensive tool
[Music]